One cool thing you can do with a square that has a transparency map is to
create a bunch of these and have them move around. When a large number of
objects like this move around we call them particles. This demo has 100,000
particles. One particular useful way to display particles is as if they're 2D
objects flat on the screen. The objects are actually in a 3D world, however. As
the camera moves, these objects are reoriented so that they always face
forward. In this example, we see squares moving about with each square always
facing the viewer. You can then apply texture with an alpha channel to get an
interesting look. By using transparency mapping, you can put whatever you want
on a particle. Here are a bunch of dots moving around. An advantage of
particles is that they can directly represent 3D scan to data. For example,
here's some movement data captured using a connect as displayed with particles.
Some researchers and developers are actively looking at how to use particles as
basic building blocks instead of triangles. Here's an example from Markus
Shuetz on his potree.org site that shows a realistic view made entirely of
particles. This data was captured by a laser scan system by Faro Technologies.
One advantage of particle systems is that data can be captured by a scanner and
then directly viewed. No processing is needed to reconstruct any triangles or
meshes. This program is running in the browser with more particles flowing in
and filling in the gaps the longer you view it. That's one advantage of
particles, you can stream them in as you wish, bit by bit. With triangles, you
tend to send in either some simplified mesh or the whole object, causing
objects to pop into existence. The particles themselves can be made to look
more realistic. You can use any texture you want when you're doing transparency
mapping. By using a sphere texture instead of a circle, these particles are
more convincing as 3D objects. Weather is a common use for particle systems for
making snow flakes or rain drops. For phenomena like rain, particles can have a
lifetime where they're created, fall through the sky, and when they hit the
ground, they disappear. Particles usually face the viewer. This idea of having
objects always face forward is called billboarding. It allows us to make 2D
textures seem more like 3D objects, as we've seen. This demo shows a popular
use for transparent textures on billboards, simulating clouds. This demo was by
the main author of Three.js in fact. Larger billboards of cloud shapes are
combined and overlapped to give the illusion of puffiness. I have to conclude
with one of the cliches of computer graphics, the lens flare. It's so easy to
add this effect, that it's been in many games, though there probably have been
more games with crates. The sparkling patterns that simulate interaction of
light with the cameras parts are all transparent textures whose position are
computed on the fly.